We will now study
what happens when
we merge independent
Poisson processes.
The story as well as
the final conclusion
is going to be similar to
what happened for the case
where we merged independent
Bernoulli processes.
In particular, we will see that
the merged process will also
be Poisson.
What is the story?
Suppose that you
have two light bulbs.
One of them is red and
flashes at random times that
are described according
to a Poisson process
with a certain rate, lambda1.
The other light bulb is green,
flashes also as a Poisson
process with a certain rate.
Furthermore, we assume
that the two light bulbs
are independent of each other.
If you're color blind so that
the only thing that you see
is flashes but without being
able to tell the color,
what kind of process
are you going to see?
Well, you will see a
Poisson process also,
and at this point,
you can probably
guess what the
arrival rate is going
to be for this Poisson process.
It should be the sum
of these two arrival
rates of the processes
that you started with.
So this will be our
final conclusion,
but we want to verify
that this is indeed
the correct conclusion.
So let us look at the
situation in some more detail.
We have the two processes, two
arrival processes-- the red one
and the green one--
and the merged process
is formed by recording an
arrival at any time where
either of the two
processes that you
started with records an arrival.
Let us now look at
the time interval
and think about the number of
arrivals in the merged process
during this time interval.
What is that the number?
That number is equal to
the number of arrivals
that you have in the
first process plus
the number of arrivals that
you have in the second process.
Let's call those numbers N1 and
N2 so that what we have here
is N1 plus N2.
Now, N1 is a Poisson
random variable
because this is a
Poisson process.
Similarly, N2 is a
Poisson random variable.
We assume that these two
processes are independent.
Therefore, N1 plus N2 is the
sum of independent Poisson
random variables, and
therefore, N1 plus N2
is also a Poisson
random variable.
This is reassuring.
It's a good piece of evidence
that the blue process
is a Poisson process,
but this is not enough.
To argue that it is
a Poisson process,
we need to check the defining
properties of a Poisson
process.
One defining property is
the independence property.
If we take disjoint intervals,
the number of arrivals
here is independent, or
should be independent,
from the number
of arrivals there.
The argument here is exactly the
same as for the Bernoulli case,
so we will not go
through it in any detail.
We just notice that whatever
happens during that time
has to do with whatever happens
during those times in the two
processes that we started with.
And similarly, what
happens in these times
has to do with what happens
in these two processes
during those times.
Because for each one of the two
processes that we start with,
we have the Poisson assumption
so that this interval
is independent from that
interval in the sense
that arrivals here and
arrivals there are independent.
So because of this, whatever
happens during those
times has nothing
to do with whatever
happens in those times,
so number of arrivals
here is independent from the
number of arrivals there.
The other property
that we need to check
is that the probability
of recording an arrival
during a small time
interval of length delta,
that this probability
has the right scaling
properties, that it
is linear in delta,
in the length of this interval,
and that the probability of two
or more arrivals
here is negligible.
To see what happens during a
typical interval in the merged
process, we need
to consider what
is going to happen during
that typical interval
in the other two
processes and consider
all the possible combinations.
During a little
interval, the red process
is going to have zero arrivals
with this probability,
one arrival with
this probability,
and two or more arrivals
with this probability, which
is negligible.
Actually here, we're ignoring
terms of order delta squared.
These are the
correct expressions
if we only focus on terms that
are either constants or linear
in delta.
We are ignoring terms
that are of order delta
square or higher.
And similarly for
the green process,
we have these probabilities
for the number of arrivals
that may happen during
a small interval.
For the merged process, we will
have zero arrivals if and only
if we have zero arrivals
in the red process
and zero arrivals in
the green process.
The probability of these
two events happening,
because we assume that the two
processes that we started with
are independent, is
going to be the product
of the probabilities of zero
arrivals in one process times
zero arrivals in
the other process.
We multiply those two
terms, and if we throw away
the term delta squared,
which is negligible,
we see that this event is going
to happen with probability 1
minus lambda1 plus
lambda2 times delta.
What's the probability
that we get one arrival?
This is an event that
can happen in two ways.
We could have one arrival
in the red process
and zero arrivals in
the green process,
and this combination happens
with this probability.
Alternatively, we could have
one arrival in the green process
and zero arrivals
in the red process.
This is this event and it
happens with this probability.
Having one arrival
in the blue process
can happen either
this way or that way,
so the probability
of one arrival
will be the sum of
these two probabilities.
And if we throw
away terms that are
order of delta squared,
what we're left with
is just lambda1 plus
lambda2 times delta.
Finally, there's the possibility
that the blue process
is going to have two
or more arrivals.
This happens if we have one
red and one green arrival,
which happens with
this probability,
or if anyone of the processes
has two or more arrivals, which
would be terms here, here, and
these would be the scenarios.
But we notice that each
one of these scenarios
has probability that's
order of delta squared.
This term also has probability
of order delta squared,
so overall, the possibility
that the blue process has
two or more arrivals-- this is
something that has probability
that's of order delta squared.
So during a typical
small interval,
there is probability
proportional
to the length of the interval
of having one arrival,
and lambda1 plus lambda2 is the
factor of this proportionality,
and the remaining probability
is assigned to the event
that there are zero arrivals.
There's essentially
negligible probability
of having two or more
arrivals, but this
together with the
independence assumption
is exactly what comes in the
definition of a Poisson process
with an arrival rate
equal to this number.
And so we have established
that the merged process
is a Poisson process
whose rate is
the sum of the rates of the
processes that we started from.